now can i be serious
yeah be serious
tommy fury more serious more serious
okay thomas fury
fury
seems to be afraid to come to america to
fight you yeah that's what some people
would think yeah i mean look he's uh
backed out of the fight once already
with an injury that we don't know
whether or not was actually an injury
you claim that he had hurt his [ __ ]
lips yes
vaginitis oh damn and it was more of an
odor was that that
he was so bad they wouldn't let him on
the plane to come over here wow
the odor
yeah it's a new thing at the tsa oh
really
that's what the dogs are standing for
now 100
i've never said okay
he just fogged up that machine when you
throw the triangle up
here but he he actually won't go to the
embassy right now so all he has to do is
go to the embassy talk to them and they
will give him his visa so that he can
come over here and fight me yeah there's
been no action on his side of things and
he seems like he doesn't want to
actually go and do that i think he's
trying to find any way out of the fight
and who knows to be honest even if he
went to the airport to get denied entry
oh he could be making the hole he should
be making the whole thing there's no
pictures of him at the airport and like
you have to think
he's a superstar over there
yeah like he wears [ __ ] one-piece
athletic suits like floyd mayweather
looking like a [ __ ] idiot like super
stand out yeah they're gonna be like
like there's no picture of him at the
airport so he could be making the whole
entire thing up and why not just go to
the embassy get your visa and make it
happen because he might be scared maybe
i
think his brother and his dad
had some sort of a serious talk with him
potentially
that was like yo look at the way you
fought in your last fight
and you might not actually be able to
beat jake paul wow
because what a lot of people are saying
is this should be an easy victory for
him
yeah but now it looks as if
they might not feel that way yeah on
paper you know he's been boxing since he
was 12 years old
amateur career 8-0
you know legendary bloodline brother's a
heavyweight champion of the world and
then he's fighting a guy who just
started doing this
um
but
who knows what actually is going on like
i hate speculating i wish i wish
[ __ ] was just more straight up and
that's what's the problem with boxing is
so many of these big fights aren't being
made because
they have so many excuses you know
that's what's great about the ufc
actually is okay you don't want to fight
somebody there's someone else in line
and we're gonna shelf you now and like
[ __ ] off yeah um
but
in boxing these guys hide behind so many
excuses it's like tommy fury talks a big
game ksi talking all the [ __ ] time
but then they never back it up they
never want to actually do [ __ ] hmm
you think that it happened after the bet
that you made
that's what i was wondering right like
you make this million dollar bet with
what's what's the better yeah tyson
explain the bet yeah so uh tyson was
like i'll bet 100k
on tommy and i was like all right like
you made 40 million dollars last year
like let's bet some real money and he
was like all right let's make it a
million basically win or lose he's
betting on tommy
i'm obviously betting it on myself
and we were in contact with his lawyer
to put the money into escrow
but i think there is a lot of pressure
if you think about it the pressure's on
tommy yeah because he is fighting for
the professional boxers and the boxing
community
and his and his big brother his name his
last name his dad is you know
he's the one yeah he's the runt of the
family and they literally he's a good
looking run though he's a handsome guy
you know
yeah you haven't fought a more handsome
yeah i would touch his belly button of
course dude
you wouldn't take a little body shot
some tequila out of that thing no
whatever
you
if you look a little bit closer i can't
wait something happened
come on bro give us the close-ups
bros googling
get him up right there watch his laptop
fly off his [ __ ] weights right now
dude
come on get a more recent picture from
his instagram if you if you look a
little bit closer yeah something
happened in the past year where he's
starting to
really like age poorly he has this like
giant crease now it's like a it's
literally like a tarmac
in the middle of his face
there buddy
it's like this it's like crunched up
like like a beluga whale yeah and then
and then i never really realized how big
his nose is
what's wrong with big noses though dogs
you said he was good looking
but i'm i like big noses
what
okay let's look at the schnauze but that
is close to the camera
no that's a handsome turkish man right
there dude look at that guy
doesn't he look like he would like
caterpillars on his [ __ ] thing okay
the eyebrows are like very specific he
has cartoonish eyes
you could thread that bro look at you've
got your eyebrows done you know he could
make yours nice
so then get him he needs to get threaded
he could tell me bro if you're watching
this don't go to the embassy and go get
that bro i
look at how handsome he is
with the spray tan yes you hating though
[Music]
if you're in the room
what are you doing if i'm in the ring
with you you're tying him up honestly
i'd be confused i'd be thinking that
he'd be trying to give me ice cream but
taking it away
you know them turkish ice cream dudes
that go like this
you know they get my ice cream tommy
fury with your eyebrows
but those eyebrows look a little bit
more thin he's a ham he looks great
there yeah
who's that one yeah is that his wife
this is his girlfriend no disrespect you
know but he's a beefcake the dude's a
cake of beef
and now oh so he's been in america oh
yeah
so he was
it's us bro kind of like you right now
yeah i'm not but i'm not sucks i don't
think there's much to suspect here
yeah i'm fast forward we're pretty open
here
[Laughter]
what's going on is this a gay podcast
[Laughter]
come on bro you weren't the only one
left outside the house
okay but can we bring up more hot guys
who is the hottest guy besides so
[Music]
where am i right now bro but seriously
who's the hottest guy you've sparred
like
like oh my god wait wait wait
jesus
come on
i didn't mean to say that i'm sorry come
on dude that was crazy right there you
have a chance with him you think he he
kisses guys pull it up pull it up wait
what
you know you know a lot about this [ __ ]
jake bro jake can i be honest close your
enemies closer bro i know everything i
know where he
lives that was that was super crazy
you suggested i kiss him bro i'm not
trying to kill him i'm trying to
objectify him
i'm not trying to be all romantic you
know what i mean like
that's what you're going for he said
fast forward yeah but just to look and
oh [ __ ] bro what's that
yeah this is that eddie hurry
that should look like the titanic bro so
that's it what is this this is him on
his reality show
what just getting getting down with the
guy he's on like love island or some
[ __ ] like that right yeah
[Laughter]
yo he's never coming to america because
if he does
he's only coming in one place so where
is it
and your belly button
i'm gonna just call my pr team to just
get them ready to be canceled
but who is that's luka doncic
did he make out luca doncic that was
wild is this is it sentimental why but
i'm telling you i'm good
you're like you're raw you are what
i mean bro come here come
[Music]
the definition of that's how they came
up with
that
that all right
when you were watching this the first
time
come on your background
rainbow colors that's a coincidence bro
that's the coincidence hit it miles
that's a complete coincidence that the
background would be rainbow colored what
are you even talking about we would
never incorporate what is that
miles what's that get that out of here
this is the month okay exactly so what
when you were watching that
for the first time right
how fast did you nut like this
is
okay